interesting news on the Mariah Carey
front james Packers ex-fiance for back
in the 90s just offered up some advice
to Mariah
on how to get James back but apparently
Mariah doesn't need anyone's help
to lift her spirits
it seems breaking up with a billionaire
isn't so hard on the singer but yeah and
that's a big if she wants him back
another one of Packers exes wrote this
open letter offering advice Kate Fisher
who ended her engagement to James back
in 1998 says quote if you really want
him back play the game let him make the
key decisions and you may well live
happily ever after as Mariah Carey
Packer
offering insight into what went wrong
Kate points the billionaire's entourage
who allegedly made a long time difficult
quote even in the bedroom just like
Mariah James has been married twice
before and proving you can find love
again
Packers ex-wife number two Erica Packer
is now dating seal that's right
Heidi Klum's ex who do it's an
incredibly happy time in my life and
he's he's a very beautiful and magical
soul and and I feel lucky to have met
him
you